[MUSIC]
DAVID DOBKIN: I'm David Dobkin,
and I'm Dean of the
Faculty and a professor
of computer science.
JOE SCANLAN: My name
is Joe Scanlan.
I'm director of the visual arts
program here at Princeton.
DAVID DOBKIN: The exhibit is
really focused on a lot of
different kinds of things that
I've collected over time.
JOE SCANLAN: I curated the show
and I thought a show by
David in conjunction with a
class that would be about the
role or the idea of the amateur
in art would be a
perfect combination.
DAVID DOBKIN: I think the first
of the collections in my
life that's represented here
is snow globe paperweights.
I have a lot of them.
This is a snow globe
from Graceland.
This is a birthday
paperweight.
There are thousands of objects
here, and it would be fair to
say that I remember 99% of
where they came from.
JOE SCANLAN: So the class that
the exhibition is in
conjunction with is Contemporary
Art and the
Amateur, and it's offered by the
interdisciplinary doctoral
program in the humanities.
DAVID DOBKIN: There are parts
of it that have a lot of
computer science--I mean
the keyboards, the CDs,
the floppy disks.
I've taken quite a few pictures
in my day, lots of
pictures of waiters and
waitresses and menus and signs
that I saw along the way, for
example, signs that say
employees must wash hands,
signs that say
please curb your dog.
I think if it's a sign and I've
seen it, I've taken a
picture of it.
I've written software to
maintain libraries of digital
pictures, and I did this
before hashtags became
popular, but I created my own
version of hashtagging.
So they're all identified in a
way that you couldn't hope to
do without a computer.
JOE SCANLAN: It has a
kind of category.
It's known as task-based art,
and it's where the artist has
discovered that kind of state
that you go into when you're
doing something that's very
routine or repetitive, and
it's a kind of bliss.
DAVID DOBKIN: So when I get new
pennies, I have to figure
out the date.
So this is 1992.
And then I work my way around
and I say, 1995, four, three,
two, and up goes the penny.
JOE SCANLAN: I was very happy
that David agreed to do the
show in its own right as a show
by someone who's been
making work for 20 years,
if not his whole life.
And then I was also very touched
by his willingness to
be a Guinea pig, really, for the
idea of this class, and to
be an example, a shining
example, of what it wanted to
talk about.
DAVID DOBKIN: A lot the pictures
you see, a lot of
things you see constructed,
are in and of themselves
boring but if you step back and
say, well, life is really
about the details and it's the
details that make life work,
this is filled with life and
it's filled with the details
that make life work.
[MUSIC]